bonjour bonjour à tous évidemment pour
moi c'est un grand plaisir que d'être
avec vous une grande fierté d'être votre
délégué à l'environnement d'avoir
dernièrement été élu côtés de christian
à la région paca en comme
vice-présidente à l'environnement à
l'énergie à la mer aujourd'hui j'en suis
persuadé ensemble avec notre famille on
peut porter une écologie différentes on
peut porter une écologie qui soit enfin
à la fois pragmatiques réalistes et
réalisables
personnellement je sais pas ce que vous
en pensez mais les discours qu'on a
longtemps entendu culpabilisateur
anxiogène alarmiste aujourd'hui sont
d'une autre époque leur volonté de
toujours être contre tout est de ne
jamais être pour rien je suis persuadé
que c'est pas ça qui crée l'adhérence
des français sur ce grand sujet du
développement durable
c'est mon combat depuis 15 ans je me
battrai à vos côtés pour qu'ils soient
portés et aimé par les français parce
qu'aujourd'hui je suis persuadé
l'écologie l'écologie que j'aime tant
elle peut rimer avec l'économie on peut
porter un autre discours d'ouverture qui
soit sur les faits qu'ils soient
arrêtons cette pensée unique
il y à un écologiquement correct dont on
en a assez et c'est vrai que quand on
prend des positions sur tel ou tel sujet
on est tout de suite accusé
et bien moi je suis désolé je préfère
les actes les faits au simple profession
de foi
aujourd'hui ce qui me distingue
évidemment dernièrement ça a été mais
position pour les agriculteurs oui je
sais ça fait grincer des dents
je soutien aux agriculteurs et j'ai osé
le dire
les agriculteurs sont les premiers
écologistes
oui sont les premiers écologistes
pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui ce sont
eux qui construisent la biodiversité
ce sont eux dont dépend la qualité des
sols la qualité des eaux la qualité des
écosystèmes agricoles forestiers
aujourd'hui c'est avec eux qu'il faut
travailler il ne faut pas les montrer du
doigt les stigmatiser mais au contraire
il faut rassembler travailler avec eux
ils sont sur le terrain ils connaissent
le terrain c'est eux qui doivent bosser
avec les scientifiques
aujourd'hui nous devons les aider
l'agriculture il ya 20 ans n'est plus
d'actualité
ils sont les premiers à vouloir réduire
les pesticides
ils sont les premiers à avoir travaillé
avec nous nicolas sur le grenelle de
l'environnement
sur le plan ecophyto 2016 aujourd'hui
grâce à la numérisation grâce aux
développements techniques et
technologiques
on peut faire des traitements qui soit
plus précis on crée l'autonomie
énergétique des bâtiments
on a une meilleure santé des animaux un
bien-être animal qui respecte et il ya
une vraie évolution dans ce sens il faut
que nous les accompagnons dans cette
agriculture durable
mon combat pour l'environnement votre
volonté à tous d'avoir un air sain
respirer une planète en bonne santé pour
nos enfants
ce n'est pas en opposition avec le fait
que nos agriculteurs vivent dignement de
leur profession il faut travailler la
main dans la main aujourd'hui je suis
désolé mais je pense que une société
basée uniquement sur le principe de
précaution n'est plus viable il faut se
baser sur un principe de responsabilité
sur un principe d'innovation matt webber
la vie distinguer il a une éthique de
conviction une éthique de responsabilité
bien sûr qu'il nous faut un idéal mais
il ne faut pas tomber dans l'idéalisme
nous devons combattre nous ouvre à être
d'avant nous devons faire avancer notre
combat personnellement je préfère la
moitié de quelque chose que
l'intégralité de rien du tout
et aujourd'hui si certains préfèrent tu
sais il ya ce nicolas qui préfère être
en hauteur éloigné d'être observateur
et puis il y a de l'autre côté le
paysage des manuels
qui donne des leçons et qui est prêt à
toutes les compromissions pourra avoir
un poste
ce visage de l'écologie qui nous est
montré
c'est pas celui que je veux incarner
alors oui ça peut être pu faire sourire
on se pose la question pourquoi
s'engager aujourd'hui auprès de nicolas
quand les hommes et les femmes
politiques sont si mal aimé et bien moi
dans mes combats dans les aventures
personnelles
j'ai été de celle qui allait à
contre-courant je serai à vos côtés pour
porter ces idées je ne serai pas ceux
qui restent au sec sans jamais vouloir
se salir les mains
on va se retrousser les manches et ce
n'est pas ni la brutalité ni la cruauté
parfois des élus écolos radicaux qui me
fera baisser les bras
des tempêtes j'en ai vu d'autres